Hospital workers demonstrating in Paris
last week to demand better pay and
conditions the latest in a series of
protests by public sector workers in
France now trade unions want to increase
pressure on the French government
they've called for a nationwide strike
to demand higher salaries and an end to
the government's pension reform plans
this Railway union representative says
people are fed up and inflation's making
things worse
we are in a tense social situation
workers are angry about the costs going
up they see big companies making record
profits but refusing to raise salaries
so going into the streets feels like the
only way to try and force them to
increase our pay the French government
says it's doing all that it can to
Shield people from inflation its capped
energy bills for consumers offered
financial help to poorer households and
is considering a pay rise for teachers
but it is standing firm on its
controversial pension reform plans
to get out of a system in which the same
job doesn't guarantee the same pension I
say yes we will all have to work a bit
longer French president Emmanuel McGraw
has been promising to overhaul France's
complex pension system ever since his
first term in office he says it needs to
be streamlined to be made fairer he also
wants to raise the retirement age from
62 to 64 or 65.
Macross past attempts to change the
retirement age and pension scheme were
met with large protests from people who
said he was eroding their social rights
it's a real worry for him today in this
climate of anxiety inflation and high
energy prices opinion polls show that
French people are against the pension
reform being forced through so quickly
so this could be the start of a protest
movement like the one we saw in macron's
first term with the yellow vests
the pandemic and war in Ukraine knocked
macron's reformist agenda off track he
wants to revive it and fulfill his
campaign promise but forging ahead with
his Ambitions is unlikely to be easy at
a time when people are struggling
financially at the economic Outlook is
so Bleak Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Paris